si la inclusión del tema de pérdidas y
daños en la agenda oficial de la cop 27
ha sido una noticia positiva aunque con
algunas pegas puesto que se comprometen
o no se comprometen más bien a utilizar
las palabras de compensación ni
responsabilidad pero aún así son buenas
noticias para la lucha contra el cambio
climático sobre todo para los países en
desarrollo nos acompaña Julio cardano
cordano Perdón él es el jefe de la
delegación de chile aquí en la cop 27 y
queríamos Julio gracias por estar con
nosotros en francés 24 Queríamos saber
cómo recibe chile y también si ha
hablado con algunos colegas de otros
países de América Latina la noticia de
la inclusión de pérdidas de daños en la
gente Sí bueno la inclusión de la de
pérdidas año en la agenda es una noticia
muy muy importante para todos los países
en desarrollo pero yo argumentaría
también que para toda la comunidad
internacional porque pérdidas de daño se
refiere a los procesos que están más
allá de la capacidad tendría que tener
los países de adaptarse a los eventos
extremos o a los eventos lentos de que
afectan a las poblaciones y a las
comunidades y los territorios frente al
cambio climático estamos en un momento
en que el cambio climático es visible
hay muchas daños y muchas muchos efectos
muy visibles del cambio climático y que
afectan a todos los países por lo tanto
tener esta conversaciones muy importante
para entender justamente Cómo podemos
abordar esas pérdidas de daños que ya
están más allá de nuestra capacidad de
adaptación precisamente chile tiene un
papel bastante importante en este tema
puesto que la ministra de medio ambiente
Marisa rojas es la encargada junto con
Alemania de facilitar esta conversación
qué retos se le avecinan a la ministra
de medio ambiente de chile bueno son
retos no menores
la ministra aceptó la invitación de la
presidencia de la Copa 27 que es Egipto
para facilitar esas conversaciones y sin
duda es la primera oportunidad que
tienen los países para ponerse un poco
de acuerdo en el en el panorama de
medidas y de los mecanismos que se
podrían contemplar para hacer frente a
las pérdidas y daños es importante decir
que probablemente esta conversación no
se va a acabar en esta copa es una
conversación que va más allá de Shake
pero es un momento muy importante para
iniciar esa conversación para tal vez
tirar algunas líneas de Marco de esa
conversación y por supuesto apuntar alto
no apuntar a que ojalá podamos ir y en
ayuda y tal vez más que me ayuda incluir
las miradas y las voces especialmente de
aquellos países y de aquellas
comunidades que están más vulnerables al
cambio climático Muchísimas gracias
Julio cordano jefe de la delegación de
chile aquí en la co27 hablándonos acerca
de esta primera noticia que ha traído la
co-27 la inclusión de pérdidas y daños
en la agenda oficial